a racist display at a henderson shopping
mall shocking many in the community mary
jane bellezza reports on what's causing
the outrage
community leaders filled the galleria
mall parking lot this morning to protest
a racist display that was up for several
weeks stating racism is not welcomed in
our community the national action
network and other civil rights
organizations are outraged the network
is reporting the racist display was
shown in front of families and children
from may 30th to july 5th the display by
las vegas railway society shows a black
man being prepared to be hung robert
bush the local president of the national
action network says the goal of monday's
protest is to show the community that
racism will not be tolerated and they
are demanding an apology not only was it
racist but but there are better ways
to depict black people in their history
of the railways such as blacks were the
first porters
such as blacks built most of the
railways throughout the united states if
they wanted to show history in the
united states then there was a much
better way to be able to do that than
a racist display while the galleria mall
general manager did offer an apology
bush tells me the las vegas railway
society has not yet responded initially
this was reported to the las vegas
action network through email that
display was taken down last week
reporting from sunset and stephanie
street mary jane vallieza live local now
governor sisselok tweeted about the
display today simply stating that racism
has no home in nevada and the display is
completely unacceptable and our
community deserves answers the
galleria's owner brookfield properties
also says it's disgusted by the display